rocky harbor auf beste waffe schießen
motiviert zu abbauen
doch kein mist begann was für ein
krankes zeug ist heute als willkommen
zur neuen video und direkt die vorrangig
haltet euch fest denn ich habe in diesem
video was für euch herausgesucht ist das
wird euch um stefan und der wirtsleute
ich habe ein kanal gefunden
ich weiß nicht wie ich schon gefunden
habe wahrscheinlich wurde mir
vorgeschlagen als ich bin so
abgeschreckt habe der ist wie rebecca
will aber auf crack also alles was für
beckham macht mit so fiktiven
ausgedachten personen und so tun als
wäre der game master real ist bei diesen
kanal den jetzt gleich sehen werden so
wenn rebecca der erste stock erst sind
die im vierzigsten stocker oder wird
sich halt einmal in ein video
reingekriegt das müsst ihr sehen das ist
einfach ist so geil also das dreh zu
komplett frei so das ist wirklich nicht
so als hätte man sie drogen genommen und
verso vollem abtreten ich glaube gar
nicht langsam leute es geht um den kanal
was wir und genauer gesagt um das video
wir löcher yuki und stellen ihm 15
fragen also man muss ganz so toll was zu
dem kanal sein als man sich hier oben
links auf dem kanal waren hatten die
zwei jungs in diesem kanal machen die
auch in den videos erscheinen und ich
bin ganz ehrlich mit euch leute
ich bin mir noch nicht sicher ob dieser
kanal eine parodie ist wisst ihr was ich
meine also ist es ein projekt was
gemacht ist um youtube zu verarschen und
zwar zu verarschen den man es selbst
macht aber krank übertreibt entweder das
oder die jungs machen das wirklich
ernsthaft was mich ein bisschen
überrascht würde weil die sind ein
bisschen eltern wenn man würde das nicht
bedingt erwarten von denen aber ich habe
schon wieder zu viel aber wir schauen
uns video rein
das wird euch schocken halt stopp
ich habe wichtige infos
okay leute mir sicher direkt mal zwei
sachen also das erste was ich auf der
rechten seite seht leute was ist das
selbst das sich auf der rechten seite
ist es eine nonne
nein das ist irgendwann hacker von
anonymous ist er unbekannt bleiben will
nein das hier rechts ist der game master
der echte game master also wissen die
leute das ist der erste punkt wo ich so
daran festmachen dass das so rebecca
ring so auf drogen ist das rating und
sie rüber game master videos nachdenken
zu drogen nimmt und dann einfach vor dem
tunnel ist voll abdeckt egal
der game master spricht sogar in diesem
video er hat eine sprechrolle okay die
interagieren einfach mit dem game master
er ist teil der video so muss los dazu
muss man auch sagen also die jungs
bayern auf jeden fall auch gut werbung
rein ich sehe hier 123456 mit rolls also
in die mitte gesetzte werbung in dem
video sechs werbung auf 10 ist schon
saftig also ich mach ich mache selbst
nicht ganz wenig werbung was ich sagen
und ich mache drei pro video
die denken sie ich denke wir haben dem
den game master im staate game master
studiums mit 106 werbung rein ist doch
dass ich habe mir alle kommentare von
unseren fans durchgelesen und jede
einzelne gesagt dass ich euro geschwächt
in einem parkhaus brendan buckley leute
also haben wir diese beiden hughes der
auf der linken seite sehen sie aus die
mitte 20 ok ich muss dazu sagen leute
passiert sondern was wir kanal gar
nichts gegen euch sehr gut durch das
rheinwasser aufmerksamkeit generieren
angeht macht ihr das richtig aber
korrigiert mir das nicht das ist einfach
zu absurd die beiden jungs hier sind
mitte zwanzig ok und reden einfach mit
dem game master in dieser szene okay und
da sitzt alles ist ein typ also mit
nonnenkostüm ja und 16 oder muss game
master maske und erzählt irgendwas mit
ebenso ja ja das macht sie ja wir reden
mit dem game the game master gibt uns
gerade infos so dass auch sie machen
sollen
da kann ich jetzt persönlich nichts dran
finden und jeder einzelne hat gesagt
dass ich ihr geschlecht in einem
parkhaus verwendet
und das ist das ist die sache leute da
geht es direkt weiter also game master
diesen auf so einem level von film
youtube film dass der game master schon
in den videos mitspielt
was schon krass leute was ist passiert
muss man seinen kopf freibekommen okay
also der game master dass das ist die
story von video der game master hat die
kommentare auf dem youtube-kanal von den
beiden jungs hier gelesen
okay der game master liest kommentare
auf den youtube kanal und gibt ihm quasi
als fiktiver ausgedachte charaktere
tipps wie sie den nächsten fiktiven
ausgedachten charaktere der scheinbar
yuki heißt fangen können
ja also soweit alles normal haben oder
[Gelächter]
zu krank also sollte weil ich weiß nicht
ich bin selbst auch nicht
ich bin auch nicht 18 also ich bin auch
selbst 23 so bin ich bin ich zu sehr aus
dem nichts heraus wenn ich mir denke das
ist vollkommen abgedreht und das ist
youtube film einfach wirklich
tunnelblick wirklich also ich das ist
wirklich geisteskranke up displays ich
will ich will ich hätte also ich muss
den clubs geben die videos sind
tatsächlich gut gemacht also vom aufbau
her so von der struktur her dass wir den
leuten zugestehen so weit will ich auch
fair sein aber deck inhalt dieser videos
also ja dann sind sie zu diesem parkhaus
und haben game master im auto und fahren
jetzt mit gamers im auto hinterher
ja da hat man damit rechnen können
auch freunde ihr könnt entscheiden
sollen wir european sorgen und
vernichten oder sollen wir in taschen
geht euch dieses bild okay also yuki ja
keine ahnung ist wahrscheinlich wieder
so ein japanisch ausgedacht das zeug ich
habe es mal die google stand irgendwie
googles grad nochmal also dieses yuki
ding sagt mir willens wickie ist so ein
internet meme was sich um den späten
michael jackson dreht und ihr seht ihr
an dem bild schon so es ist so
eigentlich michael jackson auf crack so
also michael jackson so auf vollkommen
lost dass ein ja und wenn sie jetzt um
zurückzukommen
sie stehen hier links daneben der game
master okay der game master und
vernichten oder sollen wir verschont
ja das ist vollkommen normal was hier
mache
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so geht das video weiter warum was
ist das für ein krankes zeug alter das
ist ja einfach von dem video also nach
diesem sollen wir ok vernichten kann zu
werfen für word und der intro und dann
das
wo bin ich hier gelandet was ist das
[Musik]
es galt die seidiger wer zur hölle hat
sich da dieses kostüm reingekämpft wir
haben zwei kumpels man sich gefragt denn
erster kumpel haben sie ins game master
kostüm gesteckt und lassen sich von dem
helfen ja den zweiten haben sie dieses
ebook kostüm gesteckt hier unterschiede
zwischen parkplatz 3570 und 3471 und
wurde scheinbar grad von irgendwas
getroffen und ja also es ist wirklich
absurd es ist wirklich absurd
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das also wirklich nur hate my
head an diese beiden jungs aber was zur
hölle ist dass das doch krank sowieso
einkaufen oder so in der nähe geht so
nachts und wann sonst parkhaus zurück so
teure einkäufe ins auto laden auf einmal
jeder so ein typ in game master kostüm
neben ihm zwei youtuber einer mit kamera
in der hand und filmen eine vierte
person die als komische crack michael
jackson verkleidet darum tun unsere
stadt so zu sterben wie leute an den
schock ihres lebens ist kann die machen
dieser park wo diese crack gestellt hier
einfach so rum tourt der geht eine
minute eine minute lang von euch haben
entschieden dass wir wirklich vernichten
sollen aber wenn nicht ist nicht die
richtige lösung ich versteh ich komme
nicht hinter diesen kanal
ich würde echt gern mit diesen jungs
reden und so verstehen so was geht da ab
so im hintergrund bei dessen doch safe
normal entwickelte junge männer in ihren
zwanzigern als sie machen gut gemachte
videos wie gesagt dagegen kann ich gar
nicht sagen kann ich gar nicht aber ich
mache einfach wie es darüber wie sich
mit dem game master zusammen eine woge
jagen
man sollte jedem eine zweite chance
geben
so auch am ok was meint ihr wollen wir
mitnehmen und dann zu hause können mit
immer noch vernichten was das für ein
vertracktes wesen da unten alter leute
ich könnte so viele sachen zu sagen
lasst uns zum beispiel wenn wir darüber
reden dass es am hellichten tage ist uns
die einfahrt von sonntag aus so könnte
hier mit seinem auto rein fahren und er
sich dann jedoch mit der kamera stehen
und diese vertrackte gestellt da unten
oder auch die tatsache dass jetzt alle
woki mitnehmen wollen sie sich nach
hause der ja immerhin die einfache
sammlung
youtube trend fiktiven gestalten und
chillen so zu hause mit dem game master
yuki 11 an the shelf annabelle trotzdem
und ich also in der fahrrad gehen wir
mit dem initiator des freundlichen da
waren wir froh ich bin wirklich
geschockt ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
ich das mal sehen wer da auf youtube.de
jetzt helfen sie dieser china kopie von
michael jackson auf und nehmen sie mit
nach hause
ich bin auch elke seite seht ihr das
auch zu eher in den blauen shirts ich
find der rechte ist unnormal der
erinnert ein bisschen an simon und so
von der optik und zum beispiel verlangen
dem zoff aber der linke
ich weiß dass ich in jedem shop so
innerlich tot aus wissen was ich meine
[Gelächter]
ja das ist das ist youtube 2009/10 mitte
20 sitzt mit yuki und game master auf
der rückbank und unterhält sich mit
denen so game master niveau klima das
ist ja keine falsche bewegung
dann geht die sache so zieren sich hier
sehen wir uns noch nicht kannte er noch
gefährlich seien perfekt freunde wollen
wir heute wissen wir dass auf mich
wirklich wirken das wirkt auf mich wie
wenn ich so ein albtraum haben ich weiß
nicht ob ihr albtraum habt ich hoffe
nicht zu viel oder zu oft aber wenn man
so ein albtraum hat dann wacht man am
nächsten tag auf manchmal erinnert man
sich noch dran und dann denkt man sich
so steger was war das von oriente
scheiße das macht überhaupt keinen sinn
gruß cayman freundinnen müsst aber
anstatt dass nichts passieren ganz genau
[Gelächter]
wie sie sagt ich verkehre
straßenverkehrsordnung achten während
sie in ihrem auto transportieren
da hat er das kennzeichen gesehen die
kommaustria aus baden württemberg also
stuttgarter kennzeichen da hinten ist
klar leute
wir wissen baden württemberg heute
süddeutschland ist polizei streng da ist
auch egal ob der jugi und der gamer auf
der rückbank sitzende eiskalten bußgeld
verhängt aber regt euch selber vor so
als polizist haltige so ein auto an
mal ganz ehrlich ich will gar nicht
wissen was sie machen fahren sie einfach
weiter
kiwi zu abbauen
das braucht doch kein mist was was für
ein krankes zeug ist dass dieses
komische ding jähriger mit dieser drei
euro halloween maske macht einfach die
ganze zeit zu komischen michael jackson
äußerst who
heute bin ich der einzige oder gehen bei
euch auch einfach gerade alle
gehirnzellen auf urlaub hast du uns aus
langeweile geärgert leute und dann
geht's weiter es geht komplett lost
weiter es geht noch mehr lust weiter
also dann packen die beiden jungs
scheinbar yuki bzw ihren kumpel oder
freundin was auch immer das ist in ihren
garten irgendwo in stuttgart okay im
hintergrund ist auch der pool aufgebaut
so die haben halt davor hat sich jetzt
den schuldigen sommertag gemacht und
dann so jan berg ja wir müssen jetzt das
angebot wie video drehen ja okay kommt
ja aber lasst die schule stehen die
personen auf so eine studie gesetzt hier
und stelle jetzt fragen hast du uns aus
langeweile geärgert komplett los war
selten so los beim anschauen des videos
auf youtube ich meine wir müssen es dazu
keine illusionen machen so das ist klar
der in communitys so acht jahre alt und
die nehmen das ernst ne ist klar
offensichtlicher weise leute vielleicht
könnt ihr mir diesen kanal erkennen
vielleicht hab ich ein bisschen mehr
planen davon ich hoffe nach wie vor dass
die parodie kanal ist wenn ihr dazu
irgendwas wissen leute unten damit in
die kommentare abonniert main kanal wenn
ich das video gefallen hat ein freund
jack tier trüben ein für euch
vorgeschlagenes video aus das wasser
weit von mir leute mich für eure augen
und macht's gut
[Musik]